anybody making less than 400
000 a year will not pay a single penny
in taxes
two years of free community college
trust them because what could be the
downside joe biden is about to inflate
the currency
okay we are watching it happen in real
you know when all the experts tell you
the experts the same experts who said
don't mask at the very beginning
and then they said you have to shut down
the schools and then they said you have
to keep asking even if you're vaccinated
when that same cadre the new ruling
class i talk about
this group of people and how they are
formed in my brand new book that is
coming out in july
the authoritarian moment go check that
out for pre-order right now
when this class of people tells you
anything your first move should be doubt
it doesn't mean they're wrong
but it should be down particularly when
it's overwhelming when there's a 100
consensus
ah you don't have to worry about
inflation you think yourself wait a
second we're going to try and blow 10
trillion
dollars into the american economy after
blowing seven trillion dollars into the
american economy last year minimum
above and beyond the budget and you are
and your your idea is that that we
somehow are not going to get inflation
you can guarantee that
and yet this is what is being promoted
endless spending
endless spending joe biden by again the
man cannot speak
sentient paragraphs at this point so
yesterday he just told the overt lie
that if you make under 400 thousand
dollars
you won't pay a single dollar in taxes
presumably he meant you won't pay a
single additional dollar in taxes which
again is a lie
corporate taxes hit people who make
under 400 dollars a year also the white
house says that if you're a couple
making four hundred thousand dollars a
year
that means that you will be subject to
the 400 000 penalty
so if you make 250 and your wife makes
150 or the reverse
you will be paying the same tax rate as
the guy who makes four hundred and fifty
four hundred thousand dollars a year
that's a pretty major change from his
original promise sounds like two
individuals who aren't making four
hundred thousand dollars
paying higher taxes in any case here was
joe biden just saying ridiculous things
about taxes
the reason i'm bothering to do this is i
keep hearing on the press biden's gonna
raise your taxes
anybody making less than four hundred
thousand dollars a year will not pay a
single
penny in taxes oh weird also he says
that the american families plan his new
two trillion dollar boondoggle directed
at spending more money than god has ever
seen
uh it won't add a penny to our deficit
and if you believe this
then joe biden has a bridge in brooklyn
that is available for sale
here's what the american family plan
doesn't do it doesn't add a single penny
to our deficit
it's paid for by making sure corporate
america and the wealthiest one percent
just pay their fair share i come from
the corporate capital of the world
more corporations are incorporating the
state of delaware
than all the rest of the nation combined
and i'm not anti-corporate but it's
about time they start
paying their fair share this is such a
nonsensical line whenever people like
biden say things like
they need to pay their fair share let me
explain dude
the top 10 of income earners in the
united states pay
all net taxes in the united states all
like all of them 100 net taxes in the
united states are paid by the top 10
of income earners and when you tax
corporations what do you think happens
you make them less competitive on the
world stage
they bleed down the tax increases to
consumers so prices rise
and they take more money out of the
pockets of their own employees
so that joe biden can spend it on
whatever idiotic
depends products he feels like spending
it on that day it's absurd
okay and then jill the good news is that
we have dr jill to tell us how we should
spend our money too
and honestly one of the most annoying
things in public life is when we pretend
that the spouses of people we elect are
actually elected officials i don't
understand why we do this
it makes no sense like yes my wife is a
doctor also don't come to me for medical
advice
go to my wife for medical advice i
didn't go to medical school she went to
medical school
i do politics don't go to my wife for
her political prognostications she
doesn't know things about that
why in the world do we treat the first
lady this is true by in bipartisan
fashion i don't we didn't elect
joe biden we didn't elect hillary
clinton to be the co-president of the
united states as bill clinton once
suggested
we we did not elect laura bush we did
not elect
michelle obama it seems to really only
apply with democrats where they actually
try and make the first lady into a
political figure of some sort of weight
and impact
but it is it is a point of high
irritation to me that we pretend that
the first lady should have any impact on
american public life
she's along for the ride and it would be
pres douglas emhoff
is a dude i care zero bleeps about what
doug imhof has to say he's not an
elected official
but here's joe biden jill biden who
wrote an amazing dissertation
an incredible dissertation on junior
college
when she was at the university of
delaware she worked hard for that
doctorate in for dds in education
at a university with a building named
after her husband
i mean that no no inside baseball there
at all it was probably the best
dissertation anybody ever wrote except
for how it wasn't because it's publicly
available anyway
here's dr jill the greatest doctor in
all the land explaining that in her
opinion
we should just bust out the wallet and
start spending for free
community college for everybody because
that's really what we need what we need
is credential inflation we need to make
sure that people who only graduate high
school are disadvantaged
as compared to people who go to
community college and study a couple of
years in english lit
makes perfect sense here's jill biden
saying silly things
community college graduates promot
provide
more security for their families they
invest in their local schools and
businesses
and they bring needed skills to our
workforce
helping us to meet the challenges of the
21st century
that's why we need two years of
free community college yeah
we need two free years of community two
and free chicken and everybody needs two
belly buttons
and a horse that's what we need and all
the
and blowing money into the economy it
won't have any impact at all you know
how we know won't have any impact
because the smartest people have told us
it won't have any impact at all i mean
in fact they say inflation is not going
to hurt us in any way
also new york times today widespread
commodity shortages raise inflation
fears
oh who could have predicted that blowing
needless money into an economy that's
already in a state of recovery
would inflate the currency and inflate
prices who could have predicted such a
thing except for any person who
understands how inflation works
according to the new york times in a
normal year ron whalen vice president of
roger b kennedy construction
receives one or two dear valued customer
letters from suppliers
notifying him of price increases for
certain materials this year
a stack of 30 such warnings sits on his
desk in orlando florida
alerting him that things as diverse as
lumber drywall aluminum and steel
are going to cost 10 to 20 percent more
the notices are the result of commodity
shortages that are rippling across the
united states economy as growing demand
for housing cars electronics and other
goods runs up against the supply chain
congestion and high tariffs
left behind by former president donald j
trump so i love that the first two
paragraphs they're like
look at that the prices are just
skyrocketing for this sort of stuff
trump
it's like he hasn't been president for a
while here guys
like he hasn't been here since january
and i'm noticing
that it says this year a stack of 30
such this year is 2021.
donald trump was president of the united
states for a grand total of 20 days in
2021.
now i'm no fan of tariffs but the chief
driver right now of inflation
ain't the tariffs the chief driver right
because it would have been the driver of
inflation a year ago or two years ago
the the chief driver of inflation right
now is the fact that you are blowing
into the economy money you do not need
to spend and has not been created yet
the shortages and the price increases
they are eliciting are being watched
closely by the biden administration
which is under increasing pressure from
industry groups and businesses
to take steps to ease them automakers
want the white house to help them get
the semiconductors they need to make
cars
while the housing industry is asking for
tariff relief pressure to intervene
could intensify
as the administration pushes for a
multi-trillion dollar infrastructure
investment package
that includes money for building roads
bridges and electric vehicle charging
stations
all of which could become increasingly
expensive if prices keep rising
why they haven't waited for things to
settle down and get back to normal we
keep waiting for things to settle back
and settle down and get back to normal
but they haven't said mr whalen he's
considered using other material
such as metal stud systems rather than
wood framing for some construction
projects
because the price of lumber has almost
tripled in the last year
economists and policy makers are
carefully tracking the shortages as they
hunt for signs of inflation
and companies are increasingly worried
that the price spikes may not be
temporary
oh you think oh for now the fed is not
overly concerned about the price
increases
viewing them is temporary and not the
type of inflation that could spiral out
of control
well i mean if the fed is good for one
thing it's making amazing predictions
about the economy
they did an amazing job in the lead up
to the great reset
and they did an unbelievable job and
lead up to the dot-com um and they did
an
incredible job in the lead-up to the um
yeah the the experts trust them trust
them on covet where they have been wrong
throughout
trust them when it comes to race where
they are not just wrong but evil
trust them when it comes to blowing
money into the economy we don't have
because what could be the downside what
could be the downside
and the answer of course is that the
downside is precisely the reverse of
what they are promising
less prosperity less earnings less
lifestyle less equality less equity by
the way less fairness
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic
i'd watch that make it happen gang